[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and hosted on Thursday the 13th of April
I'm Kate Andrews The Spectators
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
Adrian Wooldridge writes in this week's
cover piece about the rise of a new
Elite is meritocracy dead he'll be on
the show with Peter Hitchens
Joe Biden was in Belfast this week to
commemorate the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement Katie balls and
James heal will be on the show to give
us our politics update
Paul wood writes in this week's magazine
about a peace deal between Saudi Arabia
and Iran is it what it seems he'll be on
with Greg karlstrom and finally Mark
mason built his own coffin accidentally
he'll be on to tell us how that happened
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
and if you want to read more from The
Spectator then why not subscribe to our
magazine for just 12 pounds you can get
12 weeks in print and online and a free
20-pound Amazon voucher go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to subscribe
first up Bloomberg's Adrian Wooldridge
writes this week's cover story about the
death of meritocracy a new Progressive
aristocracy is taking over Britain and
America he says to explain he joins me
now alongside journalist Peter Hitchens
Adrian Peter thanks for joining me on
spectator TV Adrian you write the cover
for this week's magazine where you look
at a new kind of attack on meritocracy
what do you say I say essentially this
that the in the in the pre-modern world
we had a society which was hierarchical
and in which people were judged
according to their membership of groups
rather than their individual abilities
um so if you're a woman or if you're a
member of the lower classes your ipso
facto subordinate and we had since then
since about the middle of the 19th
century but before that we had a liberal
Revolution which said no you must judge
people as individuals rather than as
members of groups and you should promote
them according to their individual
merits uh rather than their group
identities
um and the most
um fulfilling version of that was the
idea of meritocracy and I think for a
long time we had this idea of
meritocracy broadening and deepening
um and particularly after the second
world war we had a sort of period in
which meritocracy was in many ways the
ruling ideology of the world then we had
the left which had done a great deal to
promote meritocracy turning against the
idea of meritocracy saying that it
perverted socialism from an idea ideal
of equality to one of uh competition
um and that you should get rid of these
awful institutions like the 11 plus and
grammar schools that anti-meritocratic
Revolution
happened but it began to run out of
steam a bit Mrs Thatcher pushed back
against it by saying that we need
meritocracy but the the the ideal
vehicle of meritocracy is the market
rather than the state
um and Tony Blair to some extent new
labor pushed back against it by
accepting League tables and academic
schools but now what we have is another
big push against meritocracy this time
it's being done in the name of woke
rather than in the name of
equality comprehensive schools
egalitarianism but it's much more
serious this time than it was last time
because it presents an alternative
hierarchy uh to the world and that
hierarchy is a hierarchy of virtue
rather than the hierarchy of
um Robin equality and what this
hierarchy does is to reinvent the
pre-modern world uh in some ways to say
that we should judge people on the basis
of their group identities this is the
right way to be looking at the world but
we must invert the old pyramid that's
oppressed groups should be judged to be
virtuous uh in the way that the old
ruling class was just to be virtuous and
that we must get it get rid of this idea
of judging people on individual merits
because it's a deceit it's a lie it's a
way of perpetuating uh privilege so this
is once once a sort of more vigorous
attack on meritocracy and an assertion
of a different way of organizing the
world organizing the world according to
according to Virtue as conceived by by
the work Elite rather than individual
merits in other words it's the most
significant attack we've seen on the
liberal idea I think in my lifetime
Peter let's break down this concept of
meritocracy a little bit it's quite
popular to say these days that
meritocracy doesn't really exist that
hard work doesn't get you anywhere what
do you make of the concept of
meritocracy do you think one exists in
the UK so a concept existed but I think
a fact is has probably always existed
naturally in the intelligent Society
tends towards a certain amount of
meritocracy any society which ignores
the existence of talent in its midst and
doesn't and doesn't bring it on and and
make the maximum use of it as a foolish
Society I think a lot of occasions
during our history when we have overcome
snobbery and all kinds of other barriers
and said to people they should be
promoted on their merits I'm not sure
the left by the way was trying to to
attack meritocracy when it when it
attacked Ground Schools particularly the
Michael Young book on the rise of the
meritocracy was was his own quirky view
that muratoxy would lead to some hideous
Society where people resented the
Justice of the position they found
themselves in I don't think most people
ever felt that the left foolishly
believed that by opening up certificates
to everybody they opened up the
knowledge they thought to go with them
to everybody and so we have a society of
of huge numbers of certificates and very
little knowledge which is is probably
not what they intended but it is what
they got
Adrian can you talk us through how you
think this latest wave started and why
you think it's arguably more intense
than previous waves well it started in
American Academia in many ways um in the
1990s with the development of of of
critical race Theory and new waves of
feminism
um and the the unique thing about these
ideas is that they started off with the
belief that judging people as
individuals and embracing the idea of
meritocracy
um is a delusion because individuals are
caught up in a web of relations which um
which are more important than their
individual qualities and because Society
is structurally unjust so the only way
to get about this is not to give into
this Bourgeois ideal of meritocracy but
to look at these structural
um problems and overcome them through
group Collective action rather than
individual action so it was it was a
university idea that's very strangely
has permeated the whole of society and
particularly it's made this strange
transition from quite radical University
departments uh or in some ways what
seemed like when Marshall University of
the parliaments to the heart of the
corporation through human resource
departments
um and human resource most corporations
now particularly in the United States
but spreading right right across the
world are committed to something called
Dei diversity equity and inclusion and
this word Equity is an extraordinarily
powerful word because it says that what
we should be aiming at in business is
not a quality of opportunity which is
the old meritocratic ideal but in some
ways the quality of results and some
strange people believe in the quality of
results but it's a very radical
reinterpretation of what Society should
be about and one of the strangest things
that's happened is that a lot of
radicals have come to the conclusion
that the best way to pursue their ends
is not by overturning capitalism but by
transforming capitalism from within
capturing things like uh like human
resource departments and working within
corporations to Define their ends in
very new ways Peter Adrian mentions
academics there and University campuses
where he thinks it started to Bubble Up
in his piece he talks about Cambridge
academic priyamvada gopal who has said
things like abolish whiteness what do
you make of this I mean should we really
be too worried about some Rogue comments
that are said from academics on
University campuses well it does seem to
spread quite quickly out of universities
isn't it so we should worry about it
because it obviously has an appeal I
think the appeal it has is the one which
Adrian mentioned in the beginning the
people virtue that we live in a society
where the the old concepts of virtue
which were based on Christianity have
more or less died away it's not it's not
known or understood as a religion or as
a set of principles or as a moral system
by millions of people who find
themselves even so craving as I think
almost everybody does for some sort of
guidance as to how to be good and here
here we have a whole new set of beliefs
which provides a set of guidance in how
to be good and it's unrecognizable and
mysterious to me because I grew up in a
different one but I think we have to
understand that fundamentally it's it's
it's however much damage it does it's
born on on the wings of a desire which
most of us can understand as reasonable
the problem is
it's wrong that they've not got they've
not got it right but they've become
obsessed with with climate change
they've become obsessed with sexual
politics and they've also become
obsessed and this I think is the result
of a definite campaign rather than a
collapse of the Christian religion
they've become obsessed with with
getting rid of the patriarchy end of uh
of actually making a profound and final
attack on what we used to view as the
family I think the real sufferer in all
this is the family and the real gainer
in the end will be the state but as with
so many disastrous developments in
modern civilization it's based on a on a
benevolent wish but unfortunately the
benevolent wish will not turn out to to
be as benevolent in practice as it was
in theory and Adrian a new cover piece
you add another element to this and you
say it's one of the biggest aspects of
this new attack on meritocracy and that
of course is race what do you think has
changed in our conversations in the West
about race over these past few years
I think what's happened with with the
the this new this version of work that
we now have is that race has become much
more Central they've sort of thrown race
into the very center of these things
um and they've added to throwing race
into the center of these things a sort
of Deceit because the notion is that the
problems the very real problems of
racial inequality can only be solved
through Collective action and through
the identification of of people with
their their racial identity rather than
with any any other sort of identity I
would say that within the meritocratic
framework we had already taken very
significant steps towards
um removing
um barriers to uh ethnic minorities
um for being successful you know in this
country we have many members of the of
ethnic minorities in the cabinet many
members of ethnic minority is doing
extremely well at school perhaps the
most successful School in the country is
the Brampton Manor Academy in uh in East
London
um so we were through meritocracy
um
addressing long-term inequalities of
opportunity but what the the work do is
to say that that's an impossibility you
can't do that that meritocracy is
inherently racist it's saturated with uh
with with racism and the only way to
overcome Injustice is not to not to look
at individual ability or individual
efforts but to have Collective uh
categories Collective struggles and a
collective focus on these hidden forces
of racism which are which are everywhere
in societies so they have as it were
they've come in at a time when when when
you know people have never been Freer
certainly in in advanced countries of of
racial
Paris Prejudice and said no no no no uh
you're wrong you're not free you're
absolutely all of these things are very
deeply involved in what you think what
you do in society and it's only through
a process of collective action
um doing the work that we can solve
these problems Peter one of the things I
found really interesting about Adrian's
cover piece is that he doesn't let the
right off the hook he talks about the
right's own assault on meritocracy
calling it the form of populist rage
rather than high Tory worry about social
Mobility what do you make of that do you
think the right is just as complicit in
this attack well there isn't really a
right left is that
themselves to be on the right who are in
many cases just Market liberals who have
no real social theory at all who've long
ago Left Behind the precepts of
Christianity who aren't socially or
morally particularly conservative and
who are happy for society to be
extremely relaxed on those on those
matters and so they haven't really got
an argument half the problem with the
supposed rice in this country is that it
has long ago accepted or failed to
challenge and therefore come to live
with the things which the left have been
demanding particularly in the in the
areas of sexual politics and of the
again the the strength and importance of
the of the married family they've just
given in they have nothing particular to
say except let's have more let's let's
have more markets let's have more free
trade how is how is this any kind of
answer to the enormous if slightly
confused and in some cases bizarre moral
array of the new of the new left which
we face you're describing the class wing
of the Tory party which I would argue
has really actually dwindled over the
years but that's that's One Wing of
course there's another Wing which I
think atrian is referring to although he
can jump in here and correct me if I'm
wrong which does to have that more
populous take actually they might be
more economically liberal more socially
conservative but crucially are quite
happy to engage in the culture wars
well I I don't see much Trish in it
honesty I I don't think that the the
occasional Jordan Peterson Outburst
makes much difference to the enormous
preponderance of the other point of view
particularly on campuses or has really
much of an answer to it if you if you
didn't fight as the as the conservative
parties of the of the western Nations
did not fight the cultural and moral
Wars of the 1950s and 1960s you haven't
got much left to say when this when when
we arrive at this stage because you've
given in over so many of the earlier
battles that you really have no position
from which to stand I think there's
maybe there's a realization which I I
think everybody who's on the
conservative side of society needs to
make that we've lost and there's very
little chance of giving anything back
and that is probably the only realistic
position to take but the reasons why we
lost was a lion in battles long ago I
would say that really and truly if you
wanted to combat these developments you
needed to come them back in the in the
late 1950s and early 1960s when the
other side were thinking very hard about
them indeed people like Roy Jenkins and
Natalie crosstons begin with and then
after that the the theorists who brought
us to what what is what became called
political correctness a huge revolution
in the way we behaved and organized our
society which the supposed right had no
answer to except more Market Adrian is
interesting to me in your piece that you
say that the conservatives essentially
should feel shame for the rise of the
woke eratocracy under their control I
mean in this country they have been in
power for well over a decade
uh absolutely I would say I would say
about the populist right I think the
populist writers is a very significant
Force primarily in the United States
this sort of Jacksonian tradition uh
that is embodied by by Trump and that's
a uh uh as a populist sentiment which is
really against Elites of various sorts
but particularly against the sort of the
pointy headed Elites of universities and
and bureaucracies and we see elements of
that in the in the conservative part
party here that's uh you know the the
the Nadine Doris talking about Posh boys
who don't know the price of milk and uh
and and all the rest of it these are
they're saying that these people are out
of touch with the the common people and
their great Common Sense uh and that
they're somehow
um deluded people I think brexit was a
manifestation of that sort of populist
anger against Trump uh obviously so I
think in the question of the
um the fight against wokery and the
laziness of the conservative party I
think wokery is the wrong answer to some
real questions uh the real questions are
why are certain groups in this country
um trapped in poverty why do other
groups continue to dominate uh society
and continue to get an unfair share of
the rewards of that society and I think
there are certain answers to that
question which can be delivered by
looking at the meritocratic tradition
and modifying it improving it for for
the modern world I think the Brampton
Manor Academy various academically
selective schools that try and reach out
to poorer people are examples of that
but we haven't pushed far enough on that
we've talked about leveling up but we
haven't talked anything
like enough about spreading Excellence
throughout the country and increasing
opportunities about the country and so
workers
has a risen party as Peter has said as a
way of slaking our our appetite for for
virtue but partly as incorrect solutions
to very very real uh problems and I
think that we have to try harder not
only to address these problems but uh
you know almost a crow that we are
addressing uh addressing them or we will
have the workers doing what what I think
they're doing which is to smuggle in a
pre-modern way of thinking about the
world into into into modernity a pretty
liberal way of looking at the world
which I think is profoundly unhelpful
Peter and Adrian thanks for joining me
now to politics President Joe Biden was
in Belfast this week to commemorate the
25th anniversary of the signing of the
Good Friday agreement we've also
discovered Labor is willing to try out a
new kind of attack ad on the prime
minister to tell us about the latest
update in politics Katie balls and James
Hill join me now
Katie and James thanks for joining me uh
Katie this week U.S President Joe Biden
has come to town he came to Belfast to
Mark the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement but he didn't stay long
yes and there is a debate as to where
this was a bilateral between rashishina
and Joe Biden or abilate a by latte is
the term used by one U.S official to the
New York Times it was that brief yeah so
brief they could not go for the an
official meeting in that sense and of
course as ever as the needy partner in
the special relationship uh the UK and
specifically dining streets I know it's
definitely a bilateral
um and also since it happened uh figures
of government say actually went on even
longer than it was meant to in the diary
and so they were really getting honest
they had two coffees
obviously works less well
um but I think I I suppose there's two
things about Joe Biden's visit so the
first of is the reason he is actually
here and that is the 25th anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement as you say and
I think when Darling Street first
imagined the trip
um The Hope had been you would have
stolen up and running and that's not
been the case and instead Joe Biden had
to use his speech in Belfast to say to
speak of his hope that the parties get
together that power sharing is restored
um which is clearly some way off and
then the second part of that is
ultimately I suppose the special
relationship from Rishi sunax
relationship with Joe Biden and in that
meeting afterwards you had the Prime
Minister quite Keen to talk up uh
progress on investment in Northern
Ireland I think this one was the
character Joe Biden was trying to dangle
which is there'll be a lot more
investment if you can you know have have
storm on in operation
um and then also talking about security
and other matters I think that given it
happened on the same day as Liz truss
gave a speech in Washington in which she
specifically cited Joe Biden as a part
of the unprecedented opposition she
faced
um on her mini budget if you remember
Joe Biden came out against the 45p tax
rate I think it served as a reminder
that while the relationship you know by
La Table lateral you know why it wasn't
the longest visitor ultimately Rishi
sunak is in a better place to have a
constructive relationship with Joe Biden
the white house that has two
predecessors and I think a lot of that's
down to the Windsor framework which yes
it hasn't restored so dormant but it
does mean that you have you know
a groundwork for much better relations
both for the US and with Europe because
you no longer have this threat of
unilateral legal action for the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill and then also I
think just richardsonx um General
approach is slightly less uh robust I
think I'd be the wrong word because I
think they're still asking things behind
the scenes but definitely in public
unlike Boris Johnson and Liz trust I
think that's volatile statements which I
think means it's easier to have a child
offensive I think there's a dangerous
journalist often we sort of jump on
things as a sign of any kind of you know
split or weakness in the relationship so
the discussion around bilateral
bilateral for instance and it's
something that happens with every prime
minister remember I think Gordon Brown
in 20089 was in America and the his
officials were briefing here lengthy
meeting with the President Obama and it
later materials has actually been a sort
of walk and talk through the kitchen of
the White House when they were
discussing how to respond to the global
financial crash I think that Rishi sunak
is a bit hindered in the respect that
you know you look at the closest
relationships between presidents and
prime ministers in the past Ronald
Reagan with that in Brooklyn and
Tony Blair to give two examples they
were forged before one of the partners
entered office so I think Margaret
Thatcher first met Ronald Reagan in the
late 1970s before she became into number
10. Richardson like obviously because
he's such a young politician novel
hasn't had those kind of connections
with the side but I think he has done
well as Katie said and I think actually
the point is after a kind of confusion
which was quite low relations because of
the issue of Northern protocol you have
to look at the kind of actual strategic
outcomes and August has been signed and
I think that is a reflection of how
important the relationship with American
Britain is even if perhaps the
protagonists don't have particularly
close or warm relationship at the time
but James A lot of people are
criticizing Joe Biden for leaving
Northern Ireland so quickly and heading
to the Republic now we all know that Joe
Biden really plays up his Heritage it's
something that means a lot to him so
this trip is probably a heartfelt one as
much as it is a political one and that
may well be where his his heart is
pulling him to but um is it right to
question why he left so quickly
especially given the nature of the
special relationship well I think it's
finished Joe Biden is that you know
there isn't the Northern Ireland
assembly which he wanted to address
because they haven't been able to
appoint a speaker to ensure that process
so there wasn't too much for him there I
think I think Katie made this point
excellently on the coffeehouse shots
yesterday which was that you know we I
think a lot of maybe Brits you know
we'll see President Biden in one way but
how he's perceived in Northline is quite
a different one you know he was meant to
be going to Northern Ireland and sort of
talked to all the parties involved in
the Storm Power
um Power sharing issue but he wasn't
seen as an honest broker by some of the
you know the dep of unionists who've
come out very strongly Against The Storm
and break so I think that there is a
danger actually if he he had been there
for a number of days and maybe made a
few more gaffes and kind of was seen as
hectoring the northern Irish that had
dangers too so he has now gone to
product Island where frankly his
sympathy's lie and it's a much more kind
of fun trip shall we say than the island
leg of the tour so he's doing things
like tree planting and seeing his old
relatives distantly removed so I'm sure
he'll enjoy that much more and Katie he
made the point before that Rishi c-neck
arguably is in a better position to have
a relationship with Joe Biden than his
two predecessors so a one-off trip
perhaps isn't the biggest deal if Joe
Biden leaves early he's in a better
position to perhaps speak to the
president whenever he wants yeah I mean
I think ultimately this is not the first
time where she's seen Eric and Joe Biden
have met since he has entered number 10.
and there is of course the big Good
Friday anniversary event coming up in
the next week and one where you have the
clintons you have King Charles and I
think perhaps in an Ideal World
um that the preference in government
would have been for Joe Biden to attend
that one and it did not work for various
holiday reasons perhaps wanting to have
the full the full stare of attention on
his trip and but I suppose where I think
there might be you know
some disappointment is the fact that you
have the coronation coming up and Joe
Biden is not planning to attend there
instead it would be his wife Jill Biden
attending in his place and I think that
would have been something which would
have been taken as I suppose a sign of
the strength the relationship had he
managed to attend it but but generally
speaking I I don't think number 10 are
particularly worried about these
opportunities
James also this week there has been a
lot of attention on Labor's new attack
ads against the Tory government and
Rishi sunak at the end of last week we
saw a new ad which got a lot of
attention over the weekend and into this
week in which the labor party suggests
that the prime minister is sympathetic
to people who would sexually abuse
children you write about it for the
magazine this week yeah so this is part
of sort of wider theme in the run-up to
the local elections this year so last
week it was a focus from labor on Law
and Order crime this week it's more cost
of living and then next week is the plan
is for health and so they released these
new graphics on Thursday last week and
it was obviously only quite Century
issue of child sex abuse and they
followed up with subsequent ones on
crime and then also taking aim at Richie
sunak's wife over her her tax Affairs as
well and our labor pulls the use of
those adverts for the time being I think
they're really seeing these May local
elections as a dry run as a dress
rehearsal as one they told me before
next year's General it's kind of seeing
what works they've taken on and number
of firm digital people that have taken
on new content producers and they want
to come see how you can get the best out
of that and I think if you talk to
people in labor there's a sort of range
of opinions as to how well they've gone
you know some of them are quite you know
phlegmatic and they say well you know we
the tour is always going to attack us we
just need to get our side out first they
were never going to play by Queensbury
rules others a little bit more cautious
and I suppose the question I really
frame at the heart of this week's column
is that
in labor have the have the ambition to
win but do they have the will are they
going to see it through are they going
to if they want to fight hard are they
going to be actually able to back it up
and you look at what happened in the two
media rounds on Good Friday and Easter
Monday with Lucy Powell and Emily
Thornbury and both of those gave I think
um less than
um less than even the convincing
performances about that and I think that
shows the difficulty facing the labor
spokesman is that if they're going to
actually campaign like a sort of vote
leave machine are they going to be as
good as Michael Gove and Boris Johnson
wearing relentlessly repeating those
messages so I still think there's a bit
of sort of in labor there's a few
tensions around that and then in terms
of the Tory response to that I think
they're waiting to see uh waiting for
the time being trying to focus on which
you seeing a building up as a competent
prime minister Kirsten really shouting
from the sidelines and then they're
going to hit back with sort of
ammunition from the Timeless DPP uh next
year
and there's the frustrations within the
different political parties about this
ad and whether or not they support it if
specifically in labor whether or not
they support it or whether or not they
think the labor party went too far I'm
curious though as to how it's Landing
with people I mean
attacking Rishi sunak on a topic like
that just doesn't feel like it's going
to seem incredible I think in a lot of
people's minds given what they know
about the current prime minister but
perhaps labor feels differently maybe
they think gosh this could have cut
through yes I think it's an interesting
one in the sense we don't yet have that
many polls back and whether it has
affect you know the main party poll
leads some people I know in focus groups
so they don't think it's Landing
particularly well and but of course
partly the point of attack campaigns
like this is not so people think what a
fantastic advert and so you entrench a
negative message and people remember
that so you know it's um it's less is
less in the sense of you know trying to
endear people to kiss Dharma and but I
think it's a higher risk for labor in
the sense that lots of people expect
labor and particularly labor voters a
high portion I like the idea of having a
political leader that acts for integrity
when they go low we go high rises above
it exactly and therefore I actually
think um it's
is more risky for labor and you can see
that in terms of the internal splits
this week to take this route because and
lots of Voters want trust and honesty
and politics no matter which party you
are but I think the particular part of
Labor that takes comfort in this idea
that they operate or they like to tell
themselves to higher standards than the
Tories and that's part and you had a
situation where the Tories this weekend
we're not going to reply to this we're
not going to say much at all that's just
wait because we think labor are going to
tear chunks out of each other and lo and
behold and to your point about how
effective it is I think speaking to the
various figures who've worked on attack
ads for the Tory party the whole point
is
you pick so many people already vaguely
think or was inside part of their mind
and then you use probably an outrageous
attack and people were not thinking this
whereas as you point out not that many
people sat home thinking you know what I
think about rishi's right he is a
pedophile sympathizer and he is lenient
on sentences and that's why I think the
first ad
um is it's you don't quite get the logic
of it now it did get them attention I
think if you look at some of the other
ads and I think non-dom is something
that you know labor plan to keep on
going on they've done it previously but
perhaps in a more personal way against
her if she's an ex-wife and I think that
least uh points to you know you think
about the big round the non-dom states
when it first came out points of
discomfort the uh you know a portion of
the public had so you can see how that
one could be used in the future but
again you have to be so careful these
attacks because as James points out you
need a party that's willing to get
behind it and there's clearly lots of
doubts but also what about when you go
too far so if you have a you know a
campaign where you go after Pacific
person if they're tax status and then
that person starts to get frets vile
abuse
um are you going to have a labor leader
who then apologizes or he says you know
that's not the thing and I think you've
got to think through it in that many
stages and so I think it's interesting
that despite all the multiple briefings
about what a Triumph this has been for
labor by figures and labor which is
partly to signal to uneasy labor MPS to
get behind the strategy it's interesting
that it's being paused and there's not
yet a date for it to come back and James
also going on this week indeed right now
is the four day walkout of the junior
doctors this is the longest strike in
NHS history uh the doctors and the
British Medical Association are calling
for a 35 pay increase for junior doctors
the government has been quite quiet so
far why do you think that is
I think there's always a risk attached
to Medical strikes I mean you remember
of course the affection that the NHS is
held in
um historically strikes involving nurses
or doctors tend to be won by the
strikers you know Margaret Thatcher had
one with the ambulance workers at the
end of the 1980s and early 1990. um so
there's that obvious reason but also I
think that there's perhaps a sense of
you know the the strike I think that the
doctors have a decent case of making AP
rights but a 35 one I think to most
people seems somewhat bit high and I
think the government are saying they
don't actually need to go another attack
anything they've made their position
clear I think they're hoping at some
point they'll come to the negotiating
table but I think if anything there's
sort of two sides positions have
hardened in recent days from some of the
rhetoric earlier and I think that as you
say cater is designed in such a way that
it's taking place within this kind of
four day week between Tuesday and Friday
of this week but of course that's in the
wider Easter you know bank holiday
period which means they're expecting 10
or 11 days of disruption so we could see
anywhere up to 300 000 appointments and
operations canceled uh Katie it doesn't
seem like the government is anywhere
near accepting the things that they're
demanding no and I think ultimately the
question is you know
where is the landing Zone because we've
obviously heard in the past there won't
be talks on these demands and then
eventually there's something I think
that he compare this to the nurses
strikes they have as much greater
sympathy when Downing Street for nurses
and also importantly much greater public
sympathy
um which clearly is a big factor in
these in these things and so that is I
think one reason I think in terms of the
junior doctors and the level they're
asking for where there's less we need to
run to it but of course at the end of
the day disruption people not getting
appointments eventually the government
will be blamed for that
um if the country doesn't feel like it's
working I think that is something which
any governing party is going to struggle
with so they'll need to find some way
for it but I I think that the level of
Demand on where the rat means this um
fight has some way to go I'll just be
interested to see how when Parliament
Returns on Monday
um I think over the recess period maybe
perhaps some of the kind of visitudes
and debates around this subject have
been sort of a bit more muted I mean
we've seen the lib Dems call for an
emergency recall at Parliament but other
than that I think perhaps something
might have had more kind of effect more
debates and it might be raised at pmqs
but obviously it hasn't been because the
recess so I'll be interested to see what
the kind of ramifications are when
Parliament comes back on Monday of
course Katie the biggest question is for
the government but there's also a
question for labor here because the BMA
is demanding such a hefty pay increase
it would be very difficult for labor to
come out and even suggest that they
would just deliver that I mean we're
talking about you know a lot of money
that would be put forward indefinitely
right because these are for not just
salaries but pensions in the future
um you know it's a tricky question for
any politician about how you fund this
yeah and labor have repeatedly fudged
their response to the strikes because
they are in a difficult place where they
don't look you know in hope to the
unions but they also don't want to um
have the you know their base and also
many of their own MPS turn against them
if you think about the Edict of you know
don't appear on the picket line and then
it's like I'm not saying exactly don't
appear on the picket line we're just
saying don't do broadcast media from the
picket line like sanitary and he got in
trouble on it the technicality there and
then Shadow cabinet members fan oh way
to you know appear near a picket line
and I think it just is one of those
things where Rachel Reeves is very
reluctant it has been the past to get
into what exact figures labor would go
for instead you hear you know let's get
these sides talking get around the table
that's what labor like to say and I
think as you get closer to an election
and as they continue to be ahead in the
polls even if it is reducing slightly
and it's much harder to get away with
that I think people are looking for
answers rather than just um a situation
where I think if you perhaps combine it
with some of the attack ads I do think a
growing theme is what is labor saying on
things because we know what they don't
like we know what they they think the
Tories are rubbish but I think the more
that this goes on and particularly I
think the attack ads have pointed out
negativity we're not coming up with
something themselves it means that you
have a situation where they're under
increasing pressure to put forward
um not their own police there are plenty
but specific answers to problems as they
come up and the unifying thing here is
the physical conservatives and Rachel
Reeves is keeping a very tight hold on
the purse string so you look at the
labor attack ads for instance they will
weakened by the fact that labor isn't
going to expand the prison estate I'm
going to put money into more prison
places for people like child sex abusers
and on this one of course as well
they're not talking about sort of funded
figure increase so I think there'll be
more constraints from the show more
calls within the shadow cabinet for
those persons perhaps be loosened but of
course so much the money is tied up in
the green New Deal project so that'll be
I think perhaps behind the scenes
attention in the months to come
Katie and James thanks for joining me
spectator contributor Paul wood writes
in this week's magazine about a
political reordering in the Middle East
old enemies seem to be making up he says
is that really such good news Paul joins
me now alongside the economist Middle
East correspondent Greg hallstrom
Paul Greg thanks for joining me on
spectator TV Paul you write for the
magazine this week about the peace deal
that has been brokered between Iran and
Saudi Arabia you also write about the
worsening tensions between Iran and
Israel and the role of China and America
in the Middle East right now talk us
through what you write for the magazine
we're calling it a peace deal
um really is an inflating what's
happened here it's normalization of
relations between two countries which
have been at each other's throats for
decades and really the the fundamentals
of the conflict hadn't changed seven
years ago uh they cut off formal
diplomatic relations
um the Saudis executed a Shia cleric and
then
um Iranian uh protesters stormed the
Saudi consulate so they've agreed to
reopen their diplomatic missions they've
agreed to talk about trade to talk about
more talks
um this certainly is a stunning upset
um not least because China brokered this
deal and not the United States but it's
not peace in our time in the Middle East
first of all the fundamentals of the
enmity between the rulers in Riyadh and
the rulers in Tehran haven't changed
after all remember that the Soviet Union
in the United States had formal
diplomatic relations during the Decades
of the Cold War
um it also means that Iran probably has
more freedom of action against Israel
and the Israelis certainly feel that
they're in a weaker position now so yes
this is a peace deal it doesn't mean
that peace is breaking out all over the
Middle East and indeed it remains as
dangerous and perhaps more dangerous
particularly because Iran may feel it
has more freedom of action against
Israel Greg what do you make of the
peace deal as Paul notes these countries
were once sworn enemies what will have
changed through this deal and I think
Paul is right to say calling it a peace
deal gives it too much credit this is a
return to the way things were in some
ways in 2015 if you go back to 2015 yes
Saudi and Iran had diplomatic relations
they had flights to each other's
countries and a bit of trade but they
were also at that point backing opposing
sides in the civil war in Syria they
were backing opposing sides in the
nascent conflict in Yemen the Saudis a
few years prior to that had accused the
Iranians of trying to assassinate their
Ambassador in Washington there were all
sorts of very deep issues in this
relationship that date back to the
Islamic revolution in 79 so what they
have agreed to now is I think out of a
sense of mutual exhaustion on both sides
to try and lower tensions and to try and
focus on domestic matters the Saudis
that really means Vision 2030 it means
their grandiose plan to diversify their
economy and try to transition it away
from oil and for the Iranians also
there's a domestic component to this the
regime in many ways you can say its
legitimacy is at perhaps the lowest
point since 1979 we saw this late last
year with months of protests against the
regime the economy is a train wreck the
currency is all but worthless and so for
both countries after a decade when they
were really at each other's throats
across the region there's a desire to at
least lower tensions enough and be able
to focus on domestic matters for a while
Paul well you say that peace dealers is
overstating what's happened the deal
certainly has a big impact on Israel and
you write in the piece it could have
especially a big impact when it comes to
Iran's nuclear facilities
well some interesting developments have
been happening in parallel to this deal
which is that the the nuclear talks
between the US others in Iran I haven't
been going out anywhere for the past
four or five months they pretty much
completely broken down and the Iranians
more or less walking away at the same
time the iaea the international atomic
energy Authority has said that the
Iranians have reached 83.7 Purity in
their refined uranium 90 is the figure
commonly held to be enough to make a
bomb so first first of all for um Saudi
Arabia to sign a deal with Iran when
this is going on is as one form of
Diplomat put it a middle finger to the
United States from Riyadh which is its
principal Ally in the region it's really
quite astonishing development and of
course the Israelis have always made
clear every single Israeli Prime
Minister has said that what they regard
as a flying Holocaust that is a nuclear
bomb atop a ballistic missile that
Tehran has control of will not be
allowed to take place I spoke to Mark
regev who's the former
um Israeli ambassador to Britain and
perhaps the most prominent spokesman for
Israel Over many years who said
um whatever the the domestic frictions
and there's Mass demonstrations again
against prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu at the moment
Israel will always coalesce when there's
an external threat and the security
establishment is United about Iran and
they will take in in
um his words whatever action they feel
is necessary that doesn't mean they're
about to press the button on some
massive and dramatic
Airaid but there's been a covert War
continuously
um for many years assassinations
um covert strikes and I think we should
be prepared to see an escalation of that
if the Iranians take that further step
and get to 90 now Israel
um according to reggae of Mark reggae of
his conversation with me last night
um doesn't think it can stop an Iranian
nuclear weapon from being made but it
believes that perhaps it can put things
back a few years
um take them back to 70 or 60 Purity buy
themselves four or five more years in
which they hope something will turn up
Greg how seriously should we take the
threat of Iran using a nuclear weapon
you're in Jerusalem now it feels like
Israel has been warning for years about
Iran's enrich attempt to enrich uranium
it's a good question and it's a question
that I'm not sure anyone has a great
answer to I mean there is a very logical
case that you can make uh that Iran even
if it had a functioning nuclear weapon
and it's still months if not years away
from that even if it made the political
decision to build one uh it's still a
ways away from that there's a very
logical argument for them not using it
this is a regime that yes is deeply
ideological has been deeply ideological
since 1979 but even more than that has
shown itself focused on
self-preservation it's not a regime that
is suicidal it's a regime that in the
1980s drank what the then supreme leader
called the poison chalice and agreed to
end the war with Iraq it's a regime that
is always placed its survival above
everything else to build and then use a
nuclear weapon would be a suicidal act
for the regime because it would invite a
response in kind from Israel from
Western powers and so I think the the
assessment that many people have
including a good number of people here
in Israel is that Iran wants a weapon
not because it plans to use it
imminently but because it wants a
nuclear deterrent it wants to be able to
prevent uh foreign powers by which of
course it means Israel and the United
States the the great Satan and the
little Satan as Iran calls them it wants
to prevent them from being able to
attack Iranian territory and so that is
the assessment of of many people of
course that's not comforting for Israeli
policy makers because they still worry
that even if Iran is not going to
imminently use that weapon having a
deeply ideological regime that is
rhetorically committed to their
destruction armed with a nuclear bomb is
an unconscionable scenario for Israeli
policy makers but again a good number of
people within the security the
intelligence apparatus here don't think
that Iran is making a bomb with the
intention of using it in the near term
but Greg do you see tensions between
Israel and Iran still worsening after
this deal has been brokered
I do I think the the deal in some ways
you could say it represents a reversal
of the trends of the past few years in
the region you go back to August 2020
and it seemed like things were going in
Israel's favor they had signed uh
diplomatic agreements with the United
Arab Emirates and then with Bahrain
Sudan Morocco there was talk of other
Arab countries including perhaps Saudi
Arabia joining the Abraham Accords and
normalizing ties with Israel it seemed
like it was consolidating its
relationships in the Arab world at a
time where Iran was diplomatically
isolated under American sanctions uh and
and where its proxies in the region
groups like Hezbollah and Lebanon Hamas
and Gaza we're we're not working
together that seems to have changed in
in the past few months we've seen those
proxies just in the past week uh worked
together as Paul notes in his piece to
fire rockets at Israel from three
different fronts from Lebanon Syria and
Gaza meanwhile the Saudis and the
Iranians are uh talking with each other
instead of being at odds with each other
so you can look at it on the surface and
say that this hurts Israel's position in
the region that said I don't think this
agreement uh fundamentally changes the
way the Gulf States Saudi in particular
view Iran they still view it as a threat
as a concern they will continue to work
with the Israelis as they have done for
years uh building a discrete in the case
of Saudi Arabia a discrete security and
intelligence sharing relationship that
has really flourished over the past
decade and so I don't think it
fundamentally changes Israel's position
in the region the the concern and the
the issue for Israel Remains the nuclear
program and it seems like that is now
unresolvable and it's more complicated
now the prospect of an Israeli strike on
the Iranians now that the Iranians and
the Saudis and the Iranians and the Gulf
States are beginning to work together
and so that does complicate whatever it
is Israel might be planning to do
and Paul regardless of any deal between
Saudi Arabia and Israel Iran back
militias are still going to be causing a
lot of trouble in the Middle East you
write in your article for the magazine
about a recent attack in Northern Israel
yeah I think that's the immediate
concern as Greg was saying we seem to be
moving closer to Israel having to take
action against the nuclear program and
this deal might be mbs's judgment that
that's now inevitable and he doesn't
want to have sidy fingerprints on this
whatsoever he can say look nothing to do
with us we've got to deal with Iran or
we've got relations with Iran but in the
meantime you've got this
um intermittent back and forth across
Israel's northern border and what
happened last week I'm speaking to you
from Beirut we are rather alarmed to see
quite a large volley of rockets and
mortars going over the border from
Southern Lebanon the biggest since 2006.
um our immediate question was is this
Hezbollah because if it is and Israel
hits back then hezbollah's got perhaps
150 000 200 000 Rockets pick your
estimate that it can fire back and
you're into a full-scale war very
quickly it turned out to be Hamas but
Hamas is backed by Iran as well hamas's
political leader happened to be visiting
Beirut and talking to the leader of
Hezbollah when these Rockets were fired
it all felt like something coordinated
and therefore I think quite threatening
to Israel so up until this point the
assumption's always been that Hezbollah
doesn't want a war with Israel I think
it would be very harmful for Hezbollah
to have that war it would hurt its
Lebanese base but if you look at the
organizational chart of Hezbollah it
goes back to Tehran and if Tehran thinks
it suits its interest to do this then it
will happen I think the danger here is
that both sides think they can carefully
calibrate things a few more Rockets from
the south of Lebanon a bit more of a a
punishing retaliation strike from Israel
but 2006 when a war blossomed out of
almost nowhere out of a small
cross-border incident shows these things
get out of control very very quickly and
this time around both sides have got
many more arms many more rockets and I
think this would be a far bloodier
engagement and one that's much more
difficult for the United States than was
to bring to a close if it starts that's
why paradoxically this peace deal
whatever we want to call it
normalization of relations between two
enemies actually makes a bigger War much
more likely much more dangerous and just
to talk about the other players a little
bit Greg the peace deal between Saudi
Arabia and Iran was brokered by China as
Paul mentioned the US has usually been
the guarantor of agreements like this
were you surprised that China was
involved
I think everyone was surprised that
China was involved I think having said
that we shouldn't overstate China's role
in this uh the first part is the first
point is the United States couldn't have
actually negotiated this deal because
the United States does not have
diplomatic relations with Iran it hasn't
had diplomatic relations with Iran uh
since the the revolution in 1979 and so
the idea that America could have been
the broker of a Saudi Iranian deal is is
an unrealistic One China also stepped in
quite late in this process the talks
between the Saudis and the Iranians
started several years ago first in Iraq
then they moved online for a time
because the the Iraqi government was
going through political paralysis at the
time and so there were talks in the the
Persian Gulf State of Oman that was a
process that went on with America's
knowledge with America's encouragement
at times so the Americans weren't
completely frozen out of this the talks
only went to China uh quite late and
sort of went over the final hurdle in
Beijing I think partly for political
reasons because both Saudi Arabia and
Iran are very keen to build relations
with China at the moment particularly
economic relations this was an
opportunity to hand the Chinese a very
easy win to walk in with what was almost
at that point a concluded deal and put
Beijing in the position of being the
host for the signing ceremony and being
the sort of guarantor of the agreement
it was a diplomatic win for China a
country that had not previously been
that engaged in diplomacy in the Middle
East but but that was only the very end
of the process it was also of course for
the Saudis who are frustrated in recent
years with America who think it has been
an unreliable partner this was a way for
them to send a message to the Americans
to demonstrate once again as they have
before that they're eager to cultivate
relations with China but those relations
only go so far there is a big economic
relationship there is a slowly growing
diplomatic relationship with China but
the core of the Saudi American
relationship the secure part of it the
Saudis is frustrated as they are with
America recognize that they don't have
anywhere else to turn at the moment for
a security guarantor America is still
the only address for that still Paul the
U.S has moved one of its submarines the
USS Florida to the Persian Gulf would
people be wrong to assume that the US is
disengaging from the Middle East
I think their attention's been elsewhere
in Ukraine perhaps Taiwan or the
perception's been that and that's a very
dangerous thing in the Middle East
perception can influence real events
um as Greg was saying the United States
still has the military Cloud China
doesn't have aircraft carriers military
bases Special Forces on the ground
America is still the power that matters
in that sense but what this deal
highlights
is a shifting economic landscape China
is the biggest customer for Saudi oil
China is the biggest customer for
Iranian gas the United States now is
self-sufficient in oil and yet somehow
American taxpayers are paying this huge
bill to maintain peace and Security in
the Middle East American troops
periodically risk their lives you have
to wonder if this will start to turn the
debate in the United States why are we
paying for China's security China's
energy security
for China to import oil at our expense I
think this might be the shifting
underlying reality in the Middle East
which will have a big effect somewhere
down the line but for the moment yes the
fundamentals haven't changed but you can
see how things will change in the future
Paul and Greg thanks for joining me
and finally spectator contributor Mark
Mason writes in this week's magazine
about how he accidentally built his own
coffin to explain Mark joins me now
Mark you write for the magazine this
week about making your own coffin tell
us about that it was supposed to be a
boat well at tennis it's technically
still is a boat right it was made as a
boat my son found one of these YouTube
videos which are normally aimed at
practical men I am completely
impractical but I looked it and thought
even I could do this it's uh essentially
a flat bottomed boat it's an open top
plywood box eight foot by two foot by
one foot and I looked at the video and I
thought even I could do that and uh
managed to make the boat of course my
son got he's 13 he got bored after about
10 minutes but I carried on so committed
I stay committed through the nails I
used twice as many nails as I should
some of them actually went through both
pieces of wood like this post you know
he's loads of glue I used enough
bathroom sealant to protect the
bathrooms from a whole housing estate
and Incredibly this thing actually
floated
and so of course my partner was hoping
as I set off from the riverbank on our
local River she was hoping it was gonna
FL it was gonna sink
[Laughter]
um it's it was floating and then as I
floated past to her great disappointment
a few minutes later I sort of lay down
in it because it's eight foot long I
could lie down in the thing and there's
a 45 degree angle at the front so I was
resting my head against it
and as I went past she said you look
like you're in a coffin now I thought
fair enough uh but then I thought why
not this could be my coffin it's the
only thing I've ever met I've ever made
I didn't mean to make it as a coffin but
now that I've actually made this thing I
thought yeah in my will I'm going to
leave enough money for a piece of
plywood to go over the top and some
nails and because it's my only moment of
practicality in my entire life I'm going
to commemorated by it being my coffin
now Mark let me ask you why you're going
to use this boat as your coffin uh is it
a because you're so proud that you've
built it it necessarily you are uh is it
B because you want to use things in a
multi-purpose way you're being a bit
Thrifty here or C is there a deeper
philosophical point to this for you well
that makes me sound like a complete sued
but yes there is a bit of the third
element in there in the it's one of my
great things I've written about this for
the magazine before I did a piece a few
years ago about death cafes where people
get together to talk about death and to
accept the fact that we are mortal when
you think about it's incredible it's the
one thing that the human beings will not
admit is that we're mortal
and it's the one thing that's certain in
life David hockney has got this great
phrase he says the cause of death is
always the same it's birth
the moment you're born you know that one
day you're going to die but we'll never
admit it that's why the response to
covid got grotesky out of control that
nobody will admit that human beings are
Immortal and we won't even use the word
dead
uh we won't talk about it we won't and
if you accept it if you accept that one
day your life is going to end
that affects how you live your life you
become much more relaxed about it you
don't become a I think that Donald Trump
has not deep down accepted that he's
going to die that's one of his that's
why he's such a ridiculous figure you
think that explains a lot it does
explain a lot yes and
the magazine this week that we sort of
have to acknowledge as people our own
mortality but do you think you would
have found such a joy in building your
boat coffin had you set out building a
coffin or do you think it's actually
brought you more joy because you had
this other purpose which has made you
think perhaps maybe a little more about
your mortality yeah it like I say it
happened by mistake anything practical
that I ever achieved in my life will
happen by mistake so you're not going to
start building coffins for loved ones to
remind them of their mortality and I'm
glad that it doesn't look like a coffin
I'm glad that it uh you know it's not
what the traditional angled shape to the
sides of it but I did think about it
around the time I was building it I was
reading a brilliant book that came out
last year by a guy called Rupert
calendar who's uh an independent
Undertaker and his book called is called
what remains and it's his critique of of
of the conventional undertaking industry
and why he does the job the way he does
it which is he's very big on the you
know you have to accept that you're
mortal being completely relaxed about it
uh one of the examples I give in the
piece not from his book from my
experience is my brother went to a
funeral where everybody met there 15
minutes before the coffin's going to get
there and next to the church was a pub
so they'd agreed that they were going to
meet at the pub they'd all got their
pint glasses and it was a funeral of a
green grocer and he was he was um taken
along his coughing was taken along to
the funeral in the back of his own van
they opened up the back doors and
everybody there chinked their pint
glasses against the coffin and Then
followed it through into the graveyard
and I think that's a wonderfully relaxed
accepting attitude to death
um and I think that having your own
coffin is is a reminder of it Nelson had
his own coffin when he won the Battle of
the Nile
a few years before he died he they got
one of the one of some of his friends
got one of the captured French ships and
tooks in the wood from it and made
Nelson a coffin and he was so chuffed
with it he used to keep it propped up in
his cabin behind the seat where he used
to eat dinner well I don't think he was
actually with him when he died but uh
and the the other one I mentioned was um
missionaries yeah late 18th century
missionaries going to South America
instead of packing their belongings in
suitcases they pack them in a coffin
because they knew they wouldn't be
coming back so my accidental cough in my
boat I might actually still use it as a
boat one day although it's a it's a
while now I'm not sure how the sealant
will be holding up it might not work uh
it's propped up behind the garden shed
and it's because it's eight feet tall I
was gonna ask where you're keeping this
it's behind the shed and just the top 18
inches or so stick out behind the shed
just that little reminder when you look
out of the window to the Garden it's
there as a reminder and it's my
equivalent of those
um people that were paid by Victorious
Roman generals used to pay someone to
follow them around because they'd be
getting a praise from everyone and they
pay someone to whisper into their ear
all the time remember you're mortal
that's what Donald Trump doesn't have
that's why it sort of keeps you grounded
literally keeps you grounded you're
going to end up in the ground well
wherever you end up it's a reminder that
one day your life's going to come to an
end and it helps you not to take it too
seriously well this was my last question
to you what is the balance here because
um you know coming to terms with your
own mortality is one thing but we have
have to take life somewhat seriously
sometimes nor do we want to hurry the
process of going into the ground so it
sounds like it sounds like for you the
balance is out of sight out of mind but
just creeping over
okay it's not it's not like the Goths
that I mean some people sleep in coffins
don't they get very very you haven't
slept well I've nodded off in the back
Garden a couple of times and it's been
lying when I've had it lying down right
you visit it from time to time yeah just
to remind you just to remind you but day
to day
it's behind the shed just yeah they're
living here top few inches are there and
I'm getting on with my life enjoying it
all the more because I know that one day
it's going to end mark thanks for
joining me
that's it for the
further you enjoy spectator TV subscribe
to our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss any of our videos
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you
foreign